congrats on a great week guys i mean how
are you feeling
oh gosh it's yeah it's amazing it's been
um you know this week's gone so quickly
it's amazing i think because the show is
a monday
by the time you get into the dance for
the following week it's almost show time
you know so it's quite daunting
and yeah we were very lucky last week we
opened the show you know you go in you
do your thing and you can relax but this
week the tension was building because we
were later in the show but so happy with
the result and how it went and the
beautiful comments that we got yeah how
proud are you of her
club
i'm super proud you know today was very
special because what had quite an
emotional morning it was a first run
through with the dress rehearsal things
in work and like we're like going over
and practicing backstage
uh tonight we took it you took it to a
different level i'm so happy super proud
of nadi like she works so she's like the
hardest work in the world like i will
like be like we good let's go home and
where she was like no can we do it one
more time can we do one time so i just
know it better i love it i love the
message from ringo
so jealous i mean what was like how are
you feeling right now
oh my goodness i couldn't believe that
because just dancing to a beatles song
literally was enough of an honor but
then to have an actual beatle wishing us
luck was yeah just i can't believe it so
cool so cool love it um obviously we
have to talk about cheryl uh and cody i
mean sort of what was uh your reactions
to finding out uh that cheryl and tessa
positive i was shocked yesterday i was
like i saw it on instagram when cheryl
posted it and i actually forwarded to
melanie i was like
oh my god the first thought i was like
have we been in touch do you know what i
mean like do we we obviously want to
stay in the competition you know what i
mean we get tested every every day and
we're very careful wear masks everywhere
but you know you don't know like you
don't know where it's around and you
know i sent cheryl flowers this morning
just to because you know i feel so bad
because i know how much she wants to get
a competition when i let cody down but
then watching their performance uh
pre-recorded in the studio it's amazing
i was like imagine if what they would do
on the night with like lighting costumes
and everything it was awesome
so
speedy recovery come back
well you know you guys made it from out
of the first elimination congrats which
i think the biggest prize of all is that
you get to do britney week now
yes i know right that was the biggest
thing i was concerned about i'm so
excited for next week and i was like
literally if i'm going home
i'll do it why would you just do it on
social media anyway i would have had to
do it
i love it i love like a fellow icon like
yourself getting to represent another
fellow icon it's just so cool
yeah absolutely and you know i'm a big
fan of britney
and yeah she's an icon we are
celebrating a wonderful artist and she's
full of girl power you know so it's
going to be really fun today we have the
best song ever yeah
that's gonna be such a good tango
anyways
um
so last thing is have any of the spice
girl fellow spice girls reached out
after week one any sort of reaction from
them
and do you know what i haven't heard
i did before i got lots and lots of
actually no maybe i'm telling fib
honestly we've been so busy i think
melanie did
did message me but they sent me so much
love and luck in the beginning
um but yeah yeah melanie said killing it
so um
yeah they're supporting me from afar
it's quite
to catch the show in the uk they don't
show it over there so you have to go
search up and find it that's a good
point well congratulations again i can't
wait to see what you guys do next week
uh best of luck guys
you